It goes, it goes, it goes, it goes,
it goes, it goes, it goes, it goes...
[BRUH]
[Swedish Gibberish]
*Clap Clap*
MEME REVIEW
[More Swedish Gibberish]
[Minecraft Death Star]
RIP Minecraft Death Star 2019-2019
[Bad version of Star Wars theme music]
[Clap] Meme [Clap] Review
Today we have a very special episode of Meme Review.
That's right, sonic focus. Finally, sonic focus!
Sonic focus, SONIC FOCUS MEMEREVIEW (ok felix we got it)
Sonic, Soni-ku, Sonic-San (seriously, felix, we got it)
Where did they go wrong? (absolutely everywhere)
You know, how did we go from
a cute little fudgeball,
to this?
Why on gods earth
does this exist? (I have no idea)
And why on Gods earth
does this exist? (Felix you really tend to overexplain today)
And why
OH GOD WHY, If I could remove anything from planet earth,
It would be the Sonic totem.
Sonic totem, please...
I can't live with this [Felix can't handle it's epicness.]
I cannot live on the same planet
I cannot share the same planet with this
When people talked about the new sonic movie
You know, there was a tiny shred of hope
People thought the dream is real. Maybe [Not really]
Vin Diesel is gonna act in it. Maybe, it
could actually be good, you know , maybe it
could be good maybe it could actually be
good. People had all kinds of crazy ideas
The fantasies went wild, but as you all
know. (weird picture but okay)
Sonic fantasies can never be quenched. They released
a teaser and people were excited
[Sonic sound effects]
[Music plays] (wow, nice prediction)
Well, what people don't understand is
that Sonic has suffered too long.
Sonic is already dead and there's
nothing that can bring him back at this
point. But what makes his downfall so
painful is that he actually used to be
cool [Are you sure about that?]
[Flute version of sonic theme plays] (I thought he was cool, Felix. Now, this is engraved in my memory)
[Why is this still playing? Help me, I'm scared of my childhood]
[Flute version of sonic theme keeps playing]
What people don't realize is that Sonic
retired long ago [laughs]
He's living happy now these are all just
stunt doubles the thing is like even the
games have been bad for so goddamn long,
and I know that anyone who says
differently, it's just purely out of
nostalgia alright, I am NOT gonna lie
the soundtrack from Sonic R does make me
feel the sunshine okay
[Music plays] (Ah, man I used to love my childhood.)
it does
[Music plays]
[Music plays and Felix dances to it]
Can you imagine a franchise recognized
by millions and millions and millions of
people, that hasn't made a decent game in what, 3 decades?
[Felix laugh]
[Live footage of the greatest sonic game ever.]
[Crab raving Sonic]
But I think what hurts the most
is that Sonic actually used to be cool,
Sonic actually used to be somebody
goddammit
Sonic used to be the cool kid in town
So now that the trailer of the film is
finally out is anyone actually surprised
that this is the best they could come up
with
It's a curse I am convinced it's a
curse at this point and you have to
understand that this comes from a place
of love, I am the number one Sonic fan-
okay maybe not, that's impossible :(
has he not suffered enough isn't it time
to just exile Sonic and never speak of
him again
wouldn't that be better how much more do
you want to see this little Hedgehog in
pain
why aren't guards earth does he look
like the kid from human Jumanji you
know they spent multi million dollars on
this right you understand that for them
to then change it as they are now saying
Sonic the Hedgehog will be designed to
be changed following criticism you know
they're just gonna have to spend even
more multi millions and everyone going
oh it's a marketing strategy what if
paramount already have a good looking
sonic design and just showed us bad
version for marketing purposes "See I
pulled a sneaky on ya" so many people
seem to share this sentiment you don't
understand no Sonic is cursed okay this
is the best they could do you had a
team of experts and this is the best they could do.
[Muttering Felix as he goes into psychosis]
Oh fricking
Nicolas Cage literally put Nicolas Cage
in the Sonics if you know what put
Nicolas Cage and a blue spray can and I
will look like a better fu-[demonitized]sonic okay
ready
after knowing that they were the reason
behind the sonic remake "Unlimited power!"
Now while God's earth they listen to
remake I know a lot of people are happy
about this saying like oh it's great you
know they're listening to criticism it's
too flippin late ok it's not gonna
change the build it's just gonna make
him look different it doesn't matter
okay it's just if they're already making
this incompetent decisions why am I
unironically pissed off about this thing
I understand Sammy now.
(Yeah, you guys should've listened to Sammy, dammit)
Except I'm 30. [We know Felix.]
god damn it Daniel, the cooler Daniel I
guess people brought up the point of how
lil they have to change for Sonic to
look somewhat decent so I guess they
thought hey alright I guess we can just
change that but also from another
perspective at this point I just want to
see it for the memes that's all I really
care about even if your expectations are
completely destroyed and your hopes are
crushed you feel no excitement about
anything else in life
memes can cure that at least these are
three sonic designs made by three
different shoddy people you can't
convince the other one yeah what did it
look so different how did this happen
why do I care I don't care I look how
many blue animations are you gonna flip
up upgrade go back I said go back see it
shouldn't be so freakin hard man the
pupil can expand up to 55% when you look
at something you love
oh my god it's adorable
good job Sega good job you did it
paramount on one hand gold on other hand
painful agonizing failure oh my god
goddamn it he looked like the dispenser
guy from Team Fortress amazing we regret
to inform you that
he decided to let you go in favor of
someone better suited for the role of
Sonic I way cuter Sonic I know who made
this but it's not listed anywhere it's a
water call it oh my god
shitty watercolour his average call yeah
Sonic is this real Sonic AMV gangster's
paradise 12 years from now there will be
a live-action Sonic will be based on my
video this cannot be real I have to
confirm this oh my god, OH MY GOD. Someone did it years ago I thought it was weird
that gangster's paradise out of all
songs - poor Sonic oh my god I need to
sit down oh it's edited it's an editor
to comment oh my god blew my mind for a
second that's the best thing I've ever
seen that's fantastic oh my god just
stop abusing Sonic
If this is not the change they make...
[Sanic noises] THEN I DON'T CARE!
It's the only change they can make to Sonic
that is acceptable. At least to my Sonic standards!
(his sonic standards are pretty high )
[Preach it Felix]
Wow see this looks really good too - is that
true that actually happened
do they not test these things so they're
not like ask people being like a hidden
survey kind of thing hey so there's this
girl and basically why does he look like
that new CGI League wowie it looks
fantastic I love it
I'm getting a message live here from
meme review saying that the new improved
trailer has been leaked let's watch
gOttA gO fASt
[Why did I spend time on captioning this, Brad help]
Jesus Christ I think I realized that
that Sonic is such a cultural phenomenon
at this point and how people perceive
him is so far away - it's kind of like
YouTube isn't it when people who want and
what they put up are so different that
this is how war starts okay if they
embrace the meme okay if Sonic movie
kind of treats itself not so seriously I
think it could actually be pretty good
but of course they're not gonna do that
that's another acceptable character
design that I will let slide again with
a disappointment at least we get some on
the positive side some new meme
templates fantastic oh oh oh oh god damn
it why didn't intend to have to always
win new Team Fortress 2 live action
movie actually looks lit it looks lit
when your mom tells you to clean your
room but she doesn't know you have 35k
camera on waiting - are you really in
charge here another new meme template
fantastic reddit after forcing Paramount
animators to redesign sonic well guess
I'm in charge now when you don't have
car no car
damn and even the means are terrible Who
am I kidding here thank you for their
support and the criticism the message is
loud and clear you aren't happy with the
design I wonder this makes me really
curious what they're gonna do
endgame or detective Pikachu sonic baby
"Found in Dumpster" why are they both
doing one at the same time surely that
can't be a coincidence right
Nintendo and Sega which has been
battling since the dawn of time releases
a live action of their biggest franchise
at the same time  no no no I don't think
so
james marsden just can't catch a break
james marsden met up with a furry animal
and he's about to bury them their
meeting furry animal is it super easy my
god Hollywood director says they'll fix
Sonic's design for the movie the movie
might lose me in potential a soul for a
soul I prefer the real style
I said the real Sonic what the frick
gotta go fast
you guys always act like you're better
than me there's only one thing that can
save Sonic one thing that can save the
sonic movie there's only one thing
Ugandan knuckles - you heard it here
first ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) - WHAT?! [NANI?] you never played tuber
simulator? [ptsshhh] You know it's fun right? I'm
not supposed to give my opinion but give
it a try and then you can tell me if
it's good or not.
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Tuber Simulator Outro Song]